This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are talking about an ancient philosophy, which I think normally conjures up an image of bottling up your emotions, pretending not to care, pushing through the hard times.
with no signs of suffering, no signs of emotion, you know, rugged men, a stiff upper lip. That is, of course, the philosophy of stoicism, as many of us think we know it. As you will come to discover in this episode, stoicism has a bit of a PR problem. It is not all about suppressing negative emotions and suffering in silence. it is actually one of the most empowering mindsets that we can develop in our 20s because of how it really helps us just ride the waves of chaos and of change that this decade is going to bring us. I personally feel like so much of my 20s has involved me trying to control everything and make everything perfect and make everything just as I imagined it.
if you can relate, I feel like this is the episode for you, because stoicism basically says, stop forcing it. Stop trying to change the things you cannot change. This 3,000-year-old philosophy is all about, instead, mastering what we can control. We can control our response to the world. We can control our actions, our attitude, our self-control. So today, let's talk about it. Let's break down what we can control, what we can't, the four cardinal virtues of stoicism, that being wisdom, justice, courage, temperance, and how exactly you and I can apply them in our 20s and beyond for a more peaceful, centered life. I also want to talk about, of course, the psychology studies, the neuroscience studies looking at what stoicism does to our brains. You know, it is one of the
most mentally rewarding and powerful ways of thinking out there, it can literally change what your brain looks like. And I think a lot of modern interpretations don't necessarily cover that and don't necessarily let us see that. So I'm so excited for this episode. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology of stoicism. Let's begin with something actually separate to the psychology we normally focus on. Let's talk about the history of stoicism. So the philosophy of stoicism, it first appeared during what is called the Hellenistic period. That's around like 400, 300 BC. And it was created by this man called Xeno of Citium. Zeno, Zeno, Zeno, Zeno, Zeno, not too sure, but let's go with Xeno. Zeno of Sitium. And he was a very wealthy, rich man.
and he miraculously survived this shipwreck. And then after the shipwreck, he came back to Athens. Whilst he was there, he was feeling very enlightened by this near-death experience, also a little bit bored. So he went into a bookshop and he found the writings of a very famous philosopher called Socrates, who you may probably have heard of. And he was so, like, enthralled by this writing, so impressed that he basically became friends with all these philosophers, he wanted to be around them all the time, he decided he was going to
become a philosopher, he changed, he had a little career change, very 20-something of him, and he started thinking a lot about life and about death and about all these other things, and through that he constructed stoicism, which developed a very large following. Fun fact, the name Stoicism actually comes from Stoiaopoli, which is painted porch, I think, in Greek, and him and his disciples used to sit on this porch and talk about life, and that's where the name Stoicism came from. Very, very whimsical. So at the heart of this philosophy is the belief that everything around us operates according to a web of cause and effect. And that results in the rational structure of the universe that the Stoics called Logos. Within this universal structure
is the core Stoic belief that the world just has to be dealt with as it is. Instead of trying to drastically change it, there is a real deep sense of acceptance. One particularly influential Stoic, his name was Epic Titus. He has a very famous quote about this where he basically says, we don't suffer from what is actually happening in our lives. We suffer because of how we interpret what is happening in our lives. basically it is our judgment of things that are happening that makes us suffer and we can change that judgment we can change that interpretation so that we suffer less in this way stoicism basically says
we can only control our own behavior and our own sense of self our own way of acting and if you're going to choose a way of acting you should aim to be kind you should aim to be tolerant you should aim to be a self-controlled individual, those are the most prized attributes of all, and through that you gain a lot of peace and clarity. To be that kind of person, you have to balance these four core attributes that we spoke about before. So wisdom, courage, justice, and temperance. Wisdom, and this is very core of stoicism, these are like the four things that you really should be. Wisdom is the ability to see what is good, bad, neutral, and to be able to question things as well and explore how things are in the world. Courage is the ability to face hard things and to be okay
with discomfort. It's the ability to be okay that life is sometimes suffering. Justice is the ability to be kind, to be fair, to be a power for good. And temperance basically means self-control, not asking or wanting for too much of anything in the world, whether that's success, validation, money, praise, substances, that sort of thing. That should be your focus. If you focus on being a good person and mastering those four things, you can change how you interpret the world so that the world feels more positive towards you. This may make us believe that stoicism is all about personal peace and nothing else. And it's actually not as self-centered as you think and it's not as passive about the lives of others as you may think.
It basically just says, thinking about how terrible the world is isn't in a change the world unless you work on being a good person. being a good stoic, being a good person, benefits others because it's only those of us who have cultivated this great internal life and this internal life of virtue who can bring about positive change and who can see the world clearly and act on what really does need fixing. And that is like the biggest goal. To give you another quote from another very famous, I guess stoic, Marcus Aurelius, basically he said, you know, stop wasting time arguing about whether the world is good, just prove that the world is good. And I genuinely think that is one of the most powerful
philosophies that we can have in this day and age. Especially like for me, I feel like that resonates so much. I find so much peace and meaning and power, I guess. Is that the right word? Yeah, power. Just knowing that I cannot change how others behave. I cannot make them do or be the kind of people that I want to be, I just have to be that person as an example. So although Stoicism has a very ancient origin, it is one of those philosophies that has survived so many versions of the world, so many versions of humanity. So where are we at with it today? Not a surprise.
Stoicism is having a bit of a moment. I've been seeing a lot of videos about it. I've been seeing a lot of content about it. I think there are a few reasons. Firstly, I think the major spike we saw in like the uptick of stoicism as a guiding psychology and philosophy happened during the COVID-19 pandemic. Where else? There was so little that we could control and there was so much isolation. And so people naturally are turning to a solution. And when they can't control anything, obviously a philosophy that says that's okay is going to be pretty alluring.
here is an interesting fact. During the lockdowns, during the pandemic, Penguin, the one of the world's biggest publishers, basically said that their books about stoicism were one of the most, the best-selling books out there. Sales of some of their texts rose by 42%, 356% in some cases, like hundreds of percentages of increases from previous years. People were really getting on the Stoicism train. And when you think about the turbulent, often terrifying world we live in, that is full of powerful leaders doing terrible things and a climate catastrophe and images of genocide and war and suffering, I think we can really see why most people aren't going any other way. And we begin to understand just where this search for meaning is really
coming from. More recently, you have probably encountered a very familiar and now very famous version of Stoicism, which is the Mel Robbins' Let Them Theory. Who hasn't heard about this book? It has had its viral moment. And the thing is, it is basically a modern practical application of some very rudimentary versions of stoic principles. It emphasizes, focuses, focus on what you can control, protecting your peace, not focusing on what you can't control. If you haven't read the Let Them Theory, if you haven't read the book, basically it says, let people be who they are and then move from there. It really highlights the dichotomy of control that Stoicism is very famous for. You have to be able to make that distinction.
What can I change in a situation? And what am I just going to pain myself and destroy myself trying to change, that being other people's thoughts, other people's actions, other people's personalities, you can't, you can't change that. So focus on what you can. And it is, you know, the Let Them Theory is a direct application in many ways of those Stoic principles about the dichotomy of control. Stoicism also really emphasizes radical acceptance, right? And that's very similar to the Let Them Theory. You know, Mel Robbins really talks about how, radical acceptance is like one of the highest forms of self-love and letting yourself, giving yourself permission to not try and control others and just focus on your own comfort and let, let yourself,
I guess, be uncomfortable in their discomfort is power. That's where you've most likely, most recently encountered stoicism. Ancient stoicism is a little bit more complex than this, though. I think that's a very fun, very rudimentary version of it. It's very powerful. But if you want to go even deeper into stoicism in its ancient form, you have to really understand, again, those core virtues and work on them. And you also have to understand the three pillars of stoicism that I don't think we've even mentioned once yet in this episode. The three pillars of stoicism beyond those four virtues we've spoken about are ethics, logic, logic, and physics. And they're interdependent, so they cannot exist without the other. Sometimes scholars
arrange these aspects of stoicism in the form of an orchard. So like logic is the enclosing wall, physics is the trees, ethics is the fruit. You need all of them to basically like bear the harvest. So the enclosing kind of wall of the orchard is the first pillar, and that is logic. Using logic, Stoics aim for discipline of perception. They aim to be able to distinguish between true perceptions and false judgments. You can see this is a theme that is coming up a lot. So basically, you cannot have a good life, you cannot be happy if you cannot remove your biases from the objective reality of existence. You need to know the difference between your assumptions and like the objective truth. Otherwise, like, you are always going to fail in logic. You're always going to
struggle with that. So we can apply this by basically having a good sense of reasoning, having a good sense of judgment, really being critical as well of our own biases and being critical of what is true. So let's take the example of, like, you know, somebody has insulted you, somebody has said something that's upset you. Your first reaction is probably going to be anger. And Stoics would say that we all often react too quickly because we're not using sound logic. We're not using an appropriate judgment when approaching a situation. Acting with anger would probably, and will, undermine the possibility of a good outcome, of a rational outcome of a better outcome for yourself. It's going to make it worse. It's maybe going to ruin a relationship.
It's maybe going to upset people further. So choosing your first reaction, choosing your first judgment is actually pursuing an irrationally bad outcome because you are not applying logic. Before you react in anger to this perceived insult, a stoic would suggest that you just consider if this person actually meant what they said to be unkind. You consider other aspects or the more objective reality of this situation. do they have a history of saying things like this to you? Is this kind of just a one-off that's really weird? Do they have a motive? Are they a mean person?
Have you actually done something that's upset them? Take this extra moment. Hone in on your logic. Explore another explanation. Say as well, they did mean that mean terrible thing that they said to you. Logically, stoicism would say, what would investing in that judgment actually help you? with. Will caring about this make your life better or worse? One of my favorite quotes, again,
from Stoicism to Live By, is like, someone despises me, that is their problem. So what? Like, you think being the victim of a mean thought is bad? Imagine being the one to think those mean thoughts every single day. Imagine being in that person's mind. Like, that would be such a sad environment to live in. And it's honestly such a waste. You have only so many minutes alive and you're spending them on somebody else. That's the life that that person is living. They're spending all those minutes that they could have for themselves on you. And honestly, I think that makes you the winner in this situation, to be honest, based on logic. Your only concern should be not doing anything terrible back, not doing anything that is deserving of those
cruel words and then moving on with your life. Seeing things more clearly, having a better take over your reactions and what is actually happening in the world is a really core part of the Stoic philosophy. And it is the enclosing wall of the orchard because without reasoning, like you cannot engage in these two other pillars, which is physics and ethics. okay, we are going to take a short break here before we get into those pillars because I promise they're not too complicated, they're not too academic or philosophical. But yeah, maybe we can go have a cup of tea. Maybe we can go take a little break from like the philosophy heavy episode. Stick with us. We'll be right back after this short break.
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got? to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade.
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid.
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesbian, Michael Marantini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any matter.
should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So after logic, we have the second pillar physics. This is not what you think it is. It basically just refers to the study of nature and as things are. Physics is described as like the trees in the orchard
because it is what everything else basically stems from, right? Stoics really thought that the universe, and still believe that the universe is this rational organism that is governed by divine reason and governed by this maybe higher power of logic. Understanding that the universe is governed by an external force, helps people achieve the discipline and self-control and self-focused that is important to be a stoic, knowing that, again, external events are out of their control, knowing that you are the only thing within your control, you are a very small creature, you're a very small being, you don't have to be worried about everything that's going on. Imagine that you lose your job or like your job hunting at the moment.
Like my boyfriend's job hunting, it's terrible. It's really like just such a slog. And this is. It's really stressful and it's really worrying and frustrating for so many reasons. But the pillar of physics basically says, recognize what about this you can change? And then give yourself grace. What can you do now? What can you take responsibility for?
Knowing the way that the universe and the world is, what is in your remit? You know, you can't change global economics. You can't change how competitive things are. But you can change your edge. You can change your approach. And this kind of just helps you again, let go and move on more quickly. Finally, ethics, the final pillar. Ethics is the fruit on the tree in the orchard.
And ethics is basically those goals, those moral, virtuous goals that the Stoics have. basically applying logic, applying physics, how are you going to be a good person? How are you going to imbue those four cardinal virtues that we've mentioned before, wisdom, justice, courage, and temperance into your life? You know, there is no point having a grounding philosophy if you cannot practice it. And that is why the fruit is so essential. philosophy is not meant to be something that is just admired. It's meant to be something that's practiced. And the ultimate aim for Stoics and for everybody is to have like a flourishing life. And especially
for the Stoics, it's to have a flourishing life that is not achieved through wealth or through external success, but through character. So it basically says everything that we've said about how the world works and your control of things in the world, it doesn't matter. how should you act so that you are your happiest and so that you are a good person and so that you have accepted the things that you can't change and basically you are focused on the things that you can. This is why I think a stoic mindset is the best mindset you can have in your 20s, which I've already said, but I need to really nail down this point. So much of our 20s is just trying to force things to happen in one specific way according to what we think would make us the happiest.
I'm going to meet the love of my life at this age. Then we're going to move cities at this time. And then by 27, 28, I'll have my dream job, my dream life. And it's all going to work out exactly as I want. But it's not always up to you. Honestly, most of it is just luck. And that really sucks. But the people who I found enjoy their 20s the most just lean so deeply into the flow of the universe that they don't, they almost don't care where they end up because they know that if they're kind and they know that if they work hard, they're going to end up somewhere amazing. And I think that is just in many ways in my many short years, like the secret to happiness. It's this strange philosophy of not holding on too tight because if it is meant to be,
it will stay and if it's not meant to be, you'll just hurt yourself more, trying to force things to be the way that you want them to be. When also, you don't always know what's going to be the best outcome. Like, you actually don't know what's going to make you happiest. You just have to be prepared for any outcome and make do with what that is and know that you can make happiness within that. Okay, so this brings us to the huge major question of the episode. What impact stoicism actually have for our brain and on our psychology. This may all sound really nice in theory. Does it actually help? It's basically what we want to talk about. And the short answer is 1,000 percent, yes, it does. In fact, new research shows that authentic stoicism, so not like the
suppress your emotions type, predicts much better well-being, a much greater sense of happiness, better friendships. And we know this from one of the biggest bodies of work done on stoicism research called the Stoics Attitude and Behaviors Scale. So there's this very famous philosopher and psychotherapist. His name is Tim Labon. And he was, was, is the lead researcher in creating this scale. And this scale basically identifies seven dimensions of stoicism and how they relate to happiness. So it gets people self-reported, asked people a bunch of questions that are kind of like thinly veiled at targeting these things like virtue, things like mindfulness, benevolence, and then it looks at how their life is turning out. Are they a happy person? This scale has been tested on thousands of people
worldwide. And not just people who say they practice stoicism, but just the average person, some of whom end up adopting stoic principles kind of by accident. And the results are so clear, people who score highly on a stoic lifestyle. Everything, like not everything, but a lot of stuff is better for them. Less anxiety, less anger, greater resilience. In contrast, people who suppress their emotions, people who don't have a guiding philosophy like stoicism, have low acceptance, more anxiety, and they don't have a core value set. So they do worse on a lot of these other scales. Neurologically as well, stoicism makes us happier, it makes us more patient, kind, better able to respond rather than react, because it allows us to interrupt the fearful
parts of our brain and redirect our behavior in that split, like 40 to 50 milliseconds, where we get a say over what we're going to do. It allows us to be present in that moment, in that choice. When you have a guiding philosophy like stoicism, it basically puts your frontal cortex more in charge, that rational part of your brain, more in charge of the fast, immediate, often irrational parts of your brain that just want you to choose and just want you to urgently do something and then often lead you down that irrational path of reacting. I think the greatest evidence of stoicism's psychological power is how
prominently it appears in palliative and chronic pain research. You know, people who are at the end of their life. People who are really sick, people who are experiencing pain on all or most days, there is increasing evidence to suggest that our beliefs about pain can actually influence our experience of pain. Now, that's not to say a positive mindset fixes anything or everything, absolutely not. No, no, no. It's basically just that in these intense situations where sometimes there is nothing that you can do, the only thing you do have control over is your mindset. And people who act on that mindset feel more empowered because it's about focusing on the thing that is for them and that they can, again, control.
One study in Victoria, in Australia, where I'm from, looked at 338 chronic pain patients from 20 to 100. and again, they measured people based on this stoic fortitude, stoic attitude quality, their ability to not endure, but their ability to accept what they were going through. And what they found was that people who measured high in these traits, they reported less depression, less anxiety, less pain severity as well. Let me give you one more piece of evidence for this, because this was also observed back in the 90s, where, again,
there was this positive association between having a stoic attitude and the quality of life for people with muscular dystrophy. The study found that when you were able to adopt this guiding philosophy, when you were able to be like, this just really sucks, these are my cards, what am I going to do with them? What cards do I have in my favor? What do I not? What am I going to do with the ones that I do? These people are happier. we will definitely get to some of the criticisms of this mindset. But when you think about it, like, stoicism is powerful because it is so therapeutic and because it really teaches acceptance. And that is why it actually does show up in so many therapeutic practices.
Cognitive behavioral therapy, for example, is a stoic therapy. It basically says, like, how you think about things influences how you behave to, towards them, which influences your life. And if you can change how you think about them, you change your perception, you can change everything else. Same with like dialectical behavior therapy that basically really emphasizes radical acceptance. Changing what you can change. Again, this like underlying philosophy and pillar that comes through this all. It's also woven into things like rational emotive behavioral therapy, which focuses on changing self-defeating attitudes in people. It's also involved in mindfulness. It's involved in family therapy systems as well.
The more you start looking for stoicism, the more you start like searching for it, the more it ends up showing up in all these places and that have evidence for helping people get better and for helping people be happier. And I feel like now that you've listened to this episode, you will start seeing it everywhere as well. It's just such a powerful way to live your life, yes, philosophically, but also psychologically. Okay, before we go any further, we do have to talk about the criticisms. I feel like I really wanted to butt in with a lot of them there, but I knew we were going to get to it. We have to talk about the downsides here because no life philosophy is immune to some problems or some hiccups. This one included, the big part of it being the toxic.
positivity, the idea that how you think about things will just change everything about the world. And we know that's not true. There's this whole thing in stoicism of like, the world has to be dealt with as it is. And you should not spend time imagining an ideal society and you should just focus on what you can do. And you should be focused on your own virtues and focused on your own logic and ethics and blah, blah, blah, blah. There are definitely some people who would look at that and would interpret this as like, head down, don't get angry, don't react. If you're a good person, you don't have anything to worry about. That's all you needed to do.
You don't need to improve anything beyond that. The world is, as it is, you have done your part. When we think about the world as it is right now, it's just not a mindset that most of us can have. It's a very problematic mindset. If we take stoicism to be that version, you know, to take. a really contemporary example, like there are people protesting against dictatorships, against injustice all over the world at the moment. And they're very rightfully angry. And they may not
be living in that moment according to the specific bylines of stoicism, but does that mean that they're doing life incorrectly? Does that mean that they're sabotaging their chances at happiness if they just focus more on what they could control? No. Like it needs to be done. And it's at moments like this, that stoicism does face accusations of being a very privileged life philosophy to follow. This notion of protecting your peace and suggesting that people's pain, for example, people's worrying and suffering could be improved with the mindset shift. That can be seen as very patronizing and probably very wrong. I think at worst, stoicism has been accused of being a lifestyle accessory to the wealthy.
and maybe a way to kind of silence some things that we should be loud about. And at its best, I think, hopefully we can understand and see stilicism as a philosophy that says, yes, the world cannot be good unless you make yourself good within it, but also you do have a duty, you do have that ethical duty to go out and do something about injustice and do something about what you're seeing around you. So when you really understand that, I think you can hopefully see that it doesn't ask you to be passive and still. It asks you to really kind of get your hands dirty at times if that is what's going to make the world better and that should be your priority. Okay, so let's leave that behind. Let's talk about how we can actually apply stoicism if that
is something you want to do and if you want some of those psychological benefits we spoke about. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of course. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hard Way and listen now.
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. One of the selling points of stoicism is ironically how cheap it is and how little it needs from you.
How do you practice everyday stoicism? Here are some examples. Firstly, you need to recognize that much of the well-being talk pushed on us today suggests that you should remain positive all the time without exception. All you should be working towards is to just be happy and to not have any negative. emotions. This is very different to Stoicism. A practice that was very popular amongst the Stoics was something called negative visualization. Basically, imagine, and this is going to sound so counter to what maybe a therapist would suggest you or somebody else, but imagine at the
Saturday of your day everything that could go wrong that day. And also then imagine all the ways that you could fix all those things that would go wrong. And then move through the day knowing that you have the tools to confront these problems. Essentially, think about the worst possible what if, and then visualize yourself still dealing with that. This is very different from being anxious all day. This is called negative visualization. It requires understanding that even if things do go wrong, it's not the end of the world.
You are able to confront issues as they arise. you are able to, no matter what it is, you will be okay, push through it. That's a very helpful practice. You could literally try tomorrow. Tomorrow, what's the worst thing that could happen in your life? Imagine it. Imagine yourself dealing with it. You're good to go. You have that armor on. I honestly think about this a lot and I think about like if it doesn't work, what's going to happen? I feel like at the moment I've been facing a lot of, like, fear of embarrassment, fear of cringe from doing parts of my job I probably should do more, posting online, that kind of stuff. And really having that mentality of like truly what's the worst, what if that could happen,
is life changing because you just put everything into perspective. What's the worst thing that could happen? Somebody could judge me. Somebody could be mad at me. That's easy. Let's move on. Let's move forward. Another very simple stoicism practice is obviously gratitude and also generosity,
taking what you have extra of, feeling grateful for it, passing it forward. One practice I saw somebody talk about similar to this is basically making a list of all the things you truly do not need in your life and then also a list of the things you do need. And then sitting with that list of all the things that you have that you don't need and feeling grateful for that, grateful for this like abundance and also more confident that there is a lot you could go without that you still have. So you don't need to worry too much about achievement. You don't need to worry too much. You'll get attached too much to money or possessions because if all of that faded, you'd still be okay. Even just simply asking yourself better questions
about your life decisions is stoicism. Asking yourself like, why do I want this? Is it because of external rewards? Is it because of my own desire? That is stoicism. asking yourself, like, who am I trying to impress? What do I think I'm controlling by trying to control these things in my life? That is stoicism. Identifying why, or the areas where you are overworking, people pleasing, overthinking, and whether that is the best logical use of your time is stoicism. A stoic practice is like basically anything that lets you be more present, that lets you see the world more clearly for what it is without self-deception, without false ideas of control, and to just see your anxieties, see your worries,
see everything that could go wrong and just get on with living and get on with being kind and get on with experiencing because, oh my God, it's going to sound so cliche, like tomorrow isn't promised. You just have to be as present as possible. So I think that's all I have time for. Thank you for listening if you have made it as far. this was definitely a very philosophy-heavy episode. I like to do one of those every once in a while.
But one that I still hope was enlightening to you. I know you're here for psychology. I feel like sometimes these go hand in hand. I hope you feel inspired to take control of what you can. I hope you feel inspired to see life more clearly. It's definitely something I'm trying to do. And I hope you feel inspired to be a good, fair, courageous person. that is something I feel very strongly about right now. I feel like it's one of the only things
we can control in such what is seemingly looks like a terrible world. So if that is the only thing you get out of this episode that you are good and you can prove that the world is good by being good, that will be enough for me. So I appreciate you listening. Thank you as always to our research team, including Lucy Davidson, for her assistance with this episode today. make sure that you are following us on Instagram. If you have not yet watched an episode on Netflix, if you are in the US or Canada, go and do that right now.
We'd love to see you over there. As always, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be. his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app,
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe. to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.